hi wir sind wieder für euch ZDF heute
live ganz herzlich willkommen bei uns im
Stream wir freuen uns sehr dass ihr bei
uns seid ja sie haben ein Zeichen
gesetzt und zwar das hier
alle Spieler der deutschen
Fußballnationalmannschaft sie haben sich
bei Mannschaftsbild vor dem ersten
Gruppenspiel heute gegen Japan den Mund
zugehalten die Botschaft die geht ganz
klar in Richtung FIFA nach dem Motto ihr
habt uns den Mund verboten ihr habt uns
verboten die One Love Bünde zu tragen
stattdessen hat DFB-Kapitän Manuel Neuer
heute die offizielle optikbinde getragen
die no Diskrimination bindet der FIFA
sie hier aber dagegen das ist
bundesinnenministerin Nancy fazer sie
hat die One Love Bünde getragen heute
auf der Tribüne und das neben den
katarischen scheiß und auch neben FIFA
Präsident Johnny Infantino die Frage die
uns deswegen heute im Stream beschäftigt
die seht ihr hier reicht dieses Zeichen
reicht diese Aktion der deutschen
Nationalmannschaft vor allem angesichts
der vergangenen Tage angesichts des
einknickens am Montag vor der FIFA und
angesichts auch unserer Diskussion heute
die wir später im Stream noch weiter
öffnen werden wieso stellt sich
eigentlich niemand gegen diese scheinbar
übermächtige FIFA
was meint ihr dazu schreibt gerne eure
Meinungen eure Stimmung in die
Kommentare in die Chats oder auch Fragen
die ihr habt geht alles auch per Mail
Adresse kommt ZDF
heute-zdf.de das nehmen wir gerne alles
mit in unsere Runde auf die ich mich
sehr sehr freue heute zum einen später
in der Sendung begrüßen wir Alexander
Koch er ist ehemaliger
stellvertretender Kommunikationschef der
FIFA und jetzt aber erstmal bei uns im
Stream Jochen Breyer ZDF Sportmoderator
auch Autor der wirklich eindrücklichen
und bemerkenswerten Dokumentation
geheime Sache Jochen schön dass du bei
uns bist richtig
und eigentlich würden wir oder wollten
wir auch tucatecual bei uns heute in der
Sendung begrüßen neun Jahre lang spielte
sie unter anderem für den HSV für den
ersten fC Köln als profi-fußballerin wir
haben jetzt gerade leider noch
technische Probleme warten ob wir die
Lösung können und dann schalten wir
tubebatteka gerne dazu Jochen solange
machen wir hier den Anfang und auch
weiter ich würde ganz gerne bei dir auch
beginnen und zwar als am Montag klar
wurde dass der DFB genauso wie die
anderen sechs Fußballverbände eben auf
das Tragen der One Love Kapitänsbinde
verzichten werden da hast du das hier
getwittert und ich da auch ganz klar
positioniert da können wir gemeinsam
drauf schauen ein Zeichen dass man nur
dann setzt wenn man dadurch keinerlei
Konsequenzen zu befürchten hat das ist
kein Zeichen heute also die Aktion Mund
zu halten vor dem Anpfiff die Meinungen
gehen auseinander das sehen wir jetzt
schon im Chat die einen sagen gutes
Zeichen die einen sagen viel zu wenig
wie ordnest du dieses Zeichen heute ein
ja ich fand es gut dass es ein Zeichen
gegeben hat weil die Alternative wäre ja
wahrscheinlich gewesen gar kein Zeichen
zu setzen und das hätte ich sehr schade
gefunden ich finde es auch gut dass man
den Eindruck hat dass diese Idee aus der
Mannschaft kam das hat ja auch Josua
Kimmich angedeutet dass man sich also
offenbar als Spieler in der Kabine
Gedanken gemacht hat welches Zeichen
können wir setzen und es ist zumindest
ein Zeichen was weltweit jetzt
fotografiert wurde weil es ist nur mal
die Situation wenn alle Fotografen
zusammenstehen und das Mannschaftsfoto
schießen natürlich sehen das nicht alle
das muss auch klar sein es ist also
nicht der sichtbarste Moment in einem
Spiel klar der sichtbar ist Moment der
sicher nach einem Torjubel was zu machen
aber wie gesagt ich finde man muss jetzt
auf den Spieler nicht weiter rumhacken
ich finde es gut dass sie sich was
überlegt haben und dass sie was gemacht
haben und
glaube dass wir die Diskussion von den
Spielern weglenken sollten und jetzt
nicht die ganze Zeit
darauf rumhacken sollten hätten die
Spieler mehr machen müssen hätten die
sich mehr positionieren müssen ich finde
es geht um die FIFA es geht um den DFB
und weniger um die Spieler selbst auf
diesen Teil der Diskussion schauen wir
auch gleich noch mal mit dir ich würde
ganz gerne noch mal auch die User
Kommentare mit reinnehmen die wir hier
schon sehen Proxima Centauri ist das z.B
er sagt dass das Zeichen nicht reicht
für ihn Zitat Haltung zeigen für
Menschenrechte bedeutet sich eben den
Mund niemals verbieten zu lassen auch
wenn es weh tut und das ist für ihn ein
trauriges Beweisfoto wie man es nicht
macht er sagt dass das peinlich sei
Hashtag keine Eier auf der anderen Seite
gibt es aber auch Kommentare die das
ähnlich sind und Denker anderer Weg sagt
zum Beispiel das ist eine gute Aktion
auch deutsche Fans Jochen vor Ort die
wollen Zeichen setzen und sie stoßen
offenbar auf Widerstand der katarischen
Sicherheitskräfte können uns gemeinsam
anschauen dass hier sind gefilmte
Aufnahmen eines deutschen Fans die er
uns gegeben hat er war beim
argentinienspiel hat da einen
regenbogenschweißband getragen und er
wurde wie das sehen wir gerade abgeführt
ähnliches hat auch banked Kunkel 24 aus
Köln erlebt und er hat uns seine
Geschichte dazu auch erzählt ich bin am
Montag bei den Niederlanden gegen
Senegal mit einer regenbogenbinde und
einem Regenbogen Schweißbahnen Stadion
gegangen war auch am Eingang erstmal
kein Problem aber als ich dann auf
meinem Platz saß und 60 Minuten spielt
Geschehen waren kam dann tatsächlich die
Polizei zu mir an und hatte mich von
meinem Platz zu dritt zu viert Weg
eskortiert und in den Katakomben hatte
dann ja so 10 bis 15 Polizisten auf mich
gewartet die stand dann im Kreis um mich
rum und habe mich dazu aufgefordert
meine Binde abzugeben und die Aussage
war dann entweder wir nehmen deine
Sachen mit oder wir nehmen dich mit und
weil ich dann keinen weiteren Stress
provozieren wollte weiß nicht so
Installation kommen lassen wollte habe
ich da gesagt gut da gibt es das ab
[Musik]
eine Konsequenzen wurden mir jetzt
erstmal nicht angedroht also es wurde
halt nur gesagt ja du gibst deine Sachen
aber dann kannst du weiter gucken und
ist danach auch nichts weiter passiert
außer dass ich halt meine Sachen nicht
mehr nicht mehr behalten habe behalten
durfte du hast heute wieder die
Regen ja das stimmt weil nur weil sie
ist mir einmal verboten haben und sich
das Feedback bekommen habe unter anderem
von der Innenministerin und von
DFB-Präsidenten dass sie da hinter mir
stehen dass sie mir zwar nicht
garantieren können dass nichts passiert
aber deswegen habe ich gesagt gut wenn
der DFB das Zeichen nicht setzen will
dann setze ich
dass die Worte von banked und nach dem
Spiel hat er uns gesagt dass er das
Zeichen heute von der deutschen
Nationalmannschaft aber gut findet
Jochen ganz kurz zu dir du hast in
deiner Dokumentation auch die
Sichtweisen der katharis offengelegt du
hast das gezeigt mit der Dokumentation
Geheimsache Katha unter anderem die
Aussagen zu homosexuellen die die
Kataris als geistigen Schaden bezeichnet
haben und sie haben aber auch das Bild
sozusagen präsentieren wollen wir heißen
ja alle willkommen auf der einen Seite
was zeigen dir und was sagen dir aber
die Handlungen die sie da offenbar jetzt
tun während
Luft war also all die Zusagen diese
gemacht haben insbesondere auch der
deutschen Innenministerin NC pesa die
mir zurückkamen aus Katar mit dem
Premierminister dort gesprochen hat und
sagte es gibt eine Sicherheitsgarantie
hierfür Fans der lgbtq-community es gibt
übrigens auch die Zusage dass die
Regenbogenfarben gezeigt werden dürfen
das war letztlich so deutlich muss man
sagen eine Lüge ebenso war es ja mit dem
mit der Erlaubnis Bier auszudenken vor
den Stadien ich meine das ist jetzt
vielleicht kein wichtiger Bereich ob
jetzt vor dem Stadion oder im Stadion
Alkohol ausgeschenkt wird ich glaube da
kann man geteilter Meinung darüber sein
das ist gut oder schlecht ist aber es
zeigt eben dieses System das getrickst
wurde das getäuscht wurde das im Vorfeld
immer gesagt wurde wir halten uns an
alle Absprachen und am Ende ist es eben
nicht so und was mich dabei am meisten
enttäuscht mich überrascht das jetzt
weniger von katarischer Seite wir haben
ja in der Doku auch gezeigt wie Katha
tickt und katat glaube ich auch ähm
eigentlich nie versucht ein anderes
Gesicht von sich zu zeigen nur was mich
extrem enttäuscht ist die FIFA bei der
Sache weil die FIFA immer jetzt an der
Seite von Katar steht und die FIFA
müsste sich am meisten aufregen weil der
FIFA wurden ja diese Versprechen auch
gemacht und ich vermisse extrem ein
Zeichen der FIFA ich vermisse ein
Zeichen von Johnny und fantino denn die
FIFA müsste sich jetzt schützen vor alle
Fans stellen und das da Regenbogenfarben
kassiert werden finde ich ein absolutes
nehmen wir gleich auch mit in unsere
Diskussion eben was es für Maßnahmen
geben könnte gegen die FIFA und ich höre
jetzt dass wir dazu schalten können die
Leitung steht ich freue mich sehr da
haben wir sie auch 9 Jahre lang spielte
sie unter anderem für den HSV und für
den ersten fC Köln in der Bundesliga
engagiert sich jetzt für Menschenrechte
und geflüchtete Menschen hallo Frau Teka
schön dass Sie bei uns im Stream sind
hallo guten Abend Frau Decker wir sind
mitten in der Diskussion und sprechen
auch gerade eben über die Aspekte und
Situationen die wir gesehen haben Jochen
Breyer hat gerade gesagt da muss jetzt
viel mehr kommen als Zeichen gegen die
FIFA wie sehen Sie das
das sehe ich tatsächlich genauso das ist
genau die Meinung die ich eben auch
vertrete dass der Druck auf die FIFA
eben erhöht werden muss und zwar nicht
nur aus der Austeilen der
Zivilbevölkerung oder eben von
Menschenrechtsorganisationen sondern
eben auch von den nationalen Verbänden
da muss der Druck einfach erhöht werden
und wir haben dieses Zeichen heute zwar
gesehen ich finde es auch einen Schritt
in die richtige Richtung definitiv weil
es ja das ist was wir irgendwie auch
eingefordert haben
nichtsdestotrotz ist es natürlich nur
ein Zeichen was nicht ausreicht
definitiv und das ist natürlich auch ein
Zeichen gewesen als Ersatz für das
eigentliche Zeichen und wo wir ja leider
so ein bisschen eingeknickt sind und
dennoch freue ich mich darüber dass wir
eben als Verband als Spieler uns dahin
stellen und eben dieses Zeichen setzen
das ist eben genau das was es braucht um
eben den Druck auf die FIFA auch zu
erhöhen und das ist genau das was ich
auch schon gesagt hat dass eben genau
das fehlt auch die die Statements die
öffentlichen Statements vom verbandseite
aus im Gegenteil dann sagt ein Infantino
eben zu WM-Teilnehmern sie sollen sich
bitte nicht äußern oder an
moralverträgen beteiligen und das ist
natürlich etwas was gar nicht geht und
das sind eben Sätze die nicht fallen
dürfen
denn Sport und Politik gehört
unmittelbar zusammen wir sehen uns auch
bei den bei der iranischen
Nationalmannschaft die diese Bühne diese
Riesen Bühne natürlich auch nutzt um
Solidarität zu zeigen für die Frauen für
die Menschen im eigenen Land und bei
denen sind es eben nicht nur sportliche
Sanktionen die Sie erwarten sondern
diese Jungs spielen in diesem Moment
auch mit dem mit ihrem Leben aber eben
auch mit dem Leben ihrer Familie und das
ist Statement das ist Haltung und das
ist das was ich mir eben Wünsche auch
auf politischer Seite und dann müssen
können und müssen wir sowohl Verbände
als auch Spieler
Verantwortung nehmen absolut also das
Zeichen der iranischen Mannschaft
parallel eigentlich ja auch zum
Ankündigung des Verzicht auf die one
love-kapitänsbinde das Schweigen der
Nationalspieler beim Singen nicht singen
der Hymne was ich in die Diskussion auch
gerne mit reinnehmen möchte ist ein
Statement eine Aussage die wir bei
unserer Recherche vor der Sendung auch
von Sven Kistner bekommen haben er ist
Sprecher der fanorganisation
querfootball Clubs und er ist einfach
auch ein ein Mensch den diese Debatte
betrifft und auch die Folgen dieses
auslassen des Zeichen der ist aus der
queren Community und er wünscht sich
einfach auch viel viel deutlichere
Zeichen wie Jochen und super wie ihr das
auch angesprochen habt die Frage die
würde ich dann ganz gerne auch von ihm
weiterleiten der eben sagt Last Weg dem
von den Spielern Jochen auch deine
Einschätzung hin zu den Verbänden Jochen
was würdest du dir da an weiteren
Zeichen dann auch vom DFB auch im
weiteren Turnier Verlauf wünschen
na ich hätte mir gewünscht ihr habt ja
mein Tweet vorhin gezeigt ich hatte mir
wirklich gewünscht dass jetzt mal der
FIFA die Stirn geboten ich glaube das
werden ganz guter Moment gewesen weil
lasst uns noch mal einen Schritt
zurückgehen diese Weltmeisterschaft hier
in Katar wir haben jetzt sehr viel
darüber gesprochen auch in den letzten
Wochen und Monaten da kulminieren ja
letztlich alle negativen Entwicklungen
im Fußball und insbesondere bei der FIFA
auch jetzt nicht nochmal alles
Stichworte zu nennen Korruption
Ausbeutung von Arbeitsmigranten in Katar
und so weiter also es läuft alles auf
diese WM zusammen es ist eine Skandal
der ich glaube so kann man es so kann
man es überspitzt formulieren und bei
dieser WM existiert jetzt die Situation
dass sieben Verbände sich für
Menschenrechte aussprechen wollen und
die FIFA verbietet das ich hätte es
wirklich gut gefunden wenn jetzt alle
sieben Verbände und das kann Deutschland
nicht alleine machen hätten wirklich
alle sieben Verbände jetzt
zusammenhalten müssen aus Europa das
sind wichtige Nationen wichtige Teams
auf die die FIFA auch nicht verzichten
möchte hätten jetzt diese Situation bei
dieser Skandal WM nutzen müssen finde
ich um ein Exempel zu statuieren und es
darauf ankommen zu lassen zu sagen nein
wir spielen jetzt mit dieser Binde und
jetzt muss die FIFA Farbe bekennen dann
hätte ja die FIFA wirklich vor den Augen
der Weltöffentlichkeit jetzt einem
Spieler der eine Binde trägt die sich
für Menschenrechte ausspricht eine gelbe
Karte zu zeigen das hätten alle gesehen
und aus meiner Sicht wäre die FIFA
planiert gewesen so gelbe Karte ja oder
nein dann wäre natürlich die Frage
gewesen gibt es noch weitere sportliche
Sanktion genau darum ging es ja in der
Diskussion aber dann hätte die FIFA
einen Land einer Mannschaft die
Deutschland Punkte abziehen müssen für
ein Statement für die Menschenrechte und
ich glaube damit wäre die FIFA endgültig
entlarvt gewesen auf der ganz großen
Weltbühne und ich hätte die Hoffnung
gehabt dass damit wenigstens mal eine
rote Linie gezogen wird bis hierhin und
nicht weiter und das sich dadurch
vielleicht mal was ändert im Weltfußball
und bei der
und doch haben der DFB und die anderen
sechs Fußballverbände das eben nicht
gemacht ist nicht darauf ankommen lassen
um diese Chance verpasst für Sie nein
knicken
absoluten einknicken und da gebe ich
auch ein paar ja auch recht wenn wir von
Haltung und Statements sprechen dann
können wir bei Menschenrechte keine
Kompromisse eingehen und das ist eben
das was wir leider getan haben wir bei
Menschenrechten gibt es keine
Kompromisse aber in dem Moment wo wir
eben da einknicken
entlarvt das auch viel unserer Seite aus
und ich finde auch dass es in dem Moment
wo diese sieben Verbände dieses Zeichen
gesetzt hätten was enorm wichtig gewesen
wäre auch für die Weltgemeinschaft die
Zukunft für alle die da gerade hingucken
das wäre das perfekte Zeichen gewesen in
die richtige Richtung und wir haben es
verpasst wir haben diesen Moment
verpasst und da gebe ich heute noch ein
paar ja tatsächlich auch recht da wäre
die FIFA am Zug gewesen und sie hätte
definitiv sich so dermaßen entlarvt dass
auch der letzte Funken an Freude an
diesem Sport und an diesem Fußball
vielleicht auch verloren gegangen wäre
und ich es tut mir leid wenn sich dann
so Statements lese wie von Thomas Müller
der dann sportliche Träume priorisiert
was ich natürlich auch sehr schade finde
und dann aber im Gegenzug diese Frauen
Nationalspielerin sehe wie Laura
Freigang Biene Svenja Hut die sich ganz
öffentlich positionieren und sagen und
zeigen vor allem nur weil ich Profi bin
schließt das nicht aus dass ich
politische Haltung habe und auch Haltung
zeigen kann und ich glaube das ist total
wichtig dass wir dass das eine eben das
andere auch nicht ausschließen dass wir
auch zeigen hey ich bin ich kann diesen
Sport lieben ich kann diesen Fußball
lieben aber bei Menschenrechten hört es
auch wenn die Menschenrechte verletzt
werden und ähm ich glaube wir haben uns
irgendwie debattieren die ganze Zeit
darüber was ist ein richtiges Zeichen
was ist das richtige Statement ich
glaube bei dieser ganzen Debatte dürfen
wir aber auch nicht vergessen sind bei
vielen Dokus natürlich jetzt auch ähm
ist das Thema gewesen auch bei meinem
Podcast aber da geht es natürlich immer
noch darum dass für diesen Sport den wir
alle so sehr lieben der uns allen so
viel gibt gegeben hat auch mir
persönlich ich trainiere junge Mädchen
im Fußball dass dieser Sport oder das
dieser Sport sozusagen Menschenleben
gekostet hat nur damit eine
Weltmeisterschaft in einem Land standen
kann was Menschenrechte mit Füßen tritt
das ist nicht das Konzept vom Fußball
dass ich kenne und lieben gelernt habe
und dass ich so sehr schätze vielen Dank
dass Sie das geteilt haben das ist ein
sehr sehr wichtiger und spannender Punkt
auch in dieser ganzen Debatte es gibt
nämlich dass das Zeichen nicht gemacht
wird natürlich super viel Kritik auch
bei uns in den Kommentaren an den DFB
aber auch teilweise an die Spieler das
ist eine Debatte wo es auch verschiedene
Meinung gibt sie haben das Statement von
Thomas Müller von gestern vor dem Spiel
angesprochen können wir uns gemeinsam
angucken das ist das Zitat was sie
glaube ich meinen und zwar wer von uns
Fußballern erwartet dass wir unseren
Vater als Sportler komplett verlassen
unsere sportlichen Träume für die wir
ein Fußballer Leben lang gearbeitet
haben aufgeben
das politisch noch deutlicher zu
positionieren der wird enttäuscht sein
und wenn wir uns die Kommentare dazu
angucken gibt es natürlich Bestätigung
auf der einen Seite aber auch deutliche
Kritik auf der anderen Seite hier zum
Beispiel einen Kommentar eines Users
wenn eine Binde zu tragen und sich damit
gegen ein System zu stellen dass die
Menschenrechte mit Füßen tritt eure
fußballerischen Träume zerstört kann ich
die Meinung nicht teilen viele Menschen
von euch würden sich wünschen mit eurer
erarbeiteten Strahlkraft ein Statement
zu setzen zu können
das würde ich ganz gerne in die Debatte
geben an Jochen du hast vorhin gesagt so
jetzt muss man eigentlich auch gucken
die Last von den Spielern zu nehmen
kannst du denn solche Meinungen auch
verstehen
ja klar natürlich also ich verstehe auch
jeden Spieler der sagt ich bin
Fußballspieler die Weltmeisterschaft ist
das wichtigste Turnier meiner Karriere
klar Thomas Müller ist schon Weltmeister
trotzdem ist natürlich eine WM das
Größte was man als Spieler mitmacht und
ich kann mir auch wirklich gut
vorstellen dass es die Spieler absolut
nervt also auch das ist total nervt das
Journalisten wie ich die andere jetzt
fordern das dann Zeichen gesetzt wird
weil man eigentlich tatsächlich WM
spielen will und mich würde es als
Spieler auch Nerven dass diese
Fußballweltmeisterschaft in Katar
stattfindet unter diesen Vorzeichen ich
meine schaut euch die Einschaltquoten an
viele Menschen in Deutschland schauen
die WM auch gar nicht das tut natürlich
eine Mannschaft denke ich auch wie die
selbst ja nicht entschieden hat dass
diese WM in Katar stattfindet also ich
verstehe die Meinung schon ich finde
auch tatsächlich das jetzt nicht ein
Thomas Müller oder ein Joshua Kimmich
oder ein Manuel Neuer diese Entscheidung
hätte treffen müssen sondern eben der
DFB und der DFB zusammen mit sieben
anderen sehr oder sechs anderen sehr
starken Verbänden und ganz ehrlich ich
glaube nicht dass die FIFA so weit
gegangen wäre sich getraut hätte diesen
Mannschaften Punkte abzuziehen für eine
Binde mit einem Herzen drauf ich glaube
das nicht und wenn sie es gemacht hätte
ich glaube dann hätte es erst rechten
Aufschrei gegeben und dann hätte sich
wirklich vielleicht was verändert also
ich beklage eher die Mutlosigkeit ich
hätte es wirklich toll gefunden denn
dieser versuch jetzt mal unternommen
worden wäre dann wäre die FIFA am Zug
gewesen und so hat man jetzt wieder
gekuscht und das Signal was davon
ausgeht ist ja die FIFA kann sich am
Ende alles erlauben sie muss nur mit
sportlichen Sanktionen und dann kuscheln
alle
vortecker noch mal zu ihnen sind ich bin
schon davon überzeugt dass der DFB in
diesem Moment also der nationale Verband
ein Rahmen hätte schaffen müssen für die
Spieler
wo dran sie sich eben auch orientieren
können das ist eben nicht passiert und
ich als ehemalige Fußballerin weiß
natürlich wie das ist und natürlich will
man einfach nur Fußball spielen aber es
ist zu wenig zu sagen die Spieler waren
irgendwie zu jung bei der WM-Vergabe
oder es ist auch zu wenig zu sagen die
soll sich irgendwie nur auf den Sport
konzentrieren und auf den Fußball ich
als Minderheit in der Minderheit weiß
dass es ganz ganz wichtig ist dass Leute
Position beziehen dass Leute laut sind
und ihre Stimme eben den geben die nicht
laut genug sein können und ich glaube
schon oder ich bin davon überzeugt dass
es eben wichtig ist dass das habe ich
eben schon mal gesagt dass es eben das
einen also du kannst diesen Sport lieben
du kannst diese Weltmeisterschaft auch
spielen sie aber zeig auch Haltung und
ich glaube Leon Goretzka hat vor dieser
Weltmeisterschaft ja ein zwei Mal auch
ein paar Interviews gegeben wo er ganz
klar sagt das entspricht nicht meinem
Werte Konsens das ist nicht das was ich
vertrete und trotzdem fliegt er dahin
und spielt diese Weltmeisterschaft und
das meine ich mit ich glaube schon dass
beides geht und ich glaube auch nicht
dass ich diese Vorbilder diese
sportlichen Vorbilder aus der
Verantwortung ziehen können denn sie
sind auch politische Vorbilder und ganz
viele junge Menschen da draußen gucken
natürlich wie verhalten sie sich wie wie
positionieren Sie sich und deswegen
finde ich schon dass sie da auch in der
Verantwortung stehen aber es stimmt der
DFB hat verpasst die Spieler nach außen
hin nach außen hin da ein entsprechendes
entsprechenden Rahmen zu geben woran
sich die Spieler eben orientieren können
das ist tatsächlich nicht passiert und
natürlich das stimmt auch können wir
jetzt nicht alles auf dem Rücken der
Spieler austragen
Frau teckerl ich würde eine user-frage
ganz gern noch anschließen die kommt von
Lukas Plön wie hätte sie das ist die
direkte Frage an Sie selbst als
Spielerin auf die Situation reagiert es
fiktiv ja aber haben sie deine Meinung
zu
ich weiß es nicht ich kann das heute
nicht sagen aber ich kann Ihnen sagen
dass ich definitiv nicht leise gewesen
wäre ich kann Ihnen sagen ich weiß nicht
ob ich diese Weltmeisterschaft gespielt
hätte was ich ihn aber sagen kann ich
wäre laut gewesen denn ich habe gerade
gesagt als Minderheit in der Minderheit
hatte ich nie eine andere Möglichkeit
ich musste immer laut sein ich bin ich
hatte keine andere Wahl sozusagen als
immer laut zu sein und deswegen hätte
ich auch in diesem Fall
mein Mund aufgemacht und wer laut
gewesen und wenn das ähm der Preis
gewesen wäre dass ich vielleicht nicht
mitfahren darf dann hätte ich das sehr
gerne in Kauf genommen
an dieser Stelle haben sie auch gerade
die Aussagen auch von einigen Spielern
auch vor der Weltmeisterschaft
angesprochen Leon Goretzka auch zu sehen
in der Dokumentation von Jochen
Geheimsache Cutter da hat er sich
geäußert die Dokumentation die ist
natürlich auch abrufbar weiterhin in der
ZDF Mediathek und auf Youtube gerne da
noch mal anschauen Jochen bevor wir dich
verabschieden du hast noch ein paar
Termine erstmal danke für deine Zeit bis
zu dem Moment wir wollen ja gleich noch
in unserer Sendung auch mit super
tackern und Alexander Koch über das
Thema sprechen DFB vs FIFA Reformpläne
der FIFA hast du da noch mal so ein
Ausblick oder auch ein Wunsch den wir
uns mit auf den Weg geben kannst wie
sich der Fußball entwickeln könnte wie
ihre Formen aussehen könnte damit wir
solche Debatten eben auch am Ende nicht
mehr führen müssen sondern die Liebe zum
Fußball auch bleibt
ja also ich finde man muss sich entweder
ehrlich machen als Fußball und das hieße
zu sagen dass die Werte die wir uns auf
die Fahne schreiben sowohl die FIFA als
auch der DFB dass die letztlich dann
doch nichts zählen wenn es hart auf hart
kommt das wäre die eine Variante oder
die zweite Variante wäre dann eben zu
sagen nee die Werte die wir uns auf die
Fahne schreiben die wollen wir auch
leben und dann muss man auch dafür
stehen diese Weltmeisterschaft in Katar
zeigt dass es am Ende vor allem ein Wert
ist der zählt und das ist das Geld Katar
hat sich diese Weltmeisterschaft mit
sehr sehr viel Geld ins Land geholt und
kann sich aufgrund seines finanziellen
Reichtums in der Fußballwelt alles
erlauben und einer wie Janine fantino
spielt dieses Spiel gerne mit und andere
im Fußball ja auch das muss man ja auch
sagen ein David Beckham zum Beispiel
bekommt 180 Millionen Dollar als
Werbeträger für Katar also Katar hat
sich den Fußball untertan gemacht
und ich würde mir wünschen dass ich ein
Verband wieder DFB dagegen stellt und
zwar richtig dagegen stellt also nicht
nur mit warmen Worten sondern
mit Taten und das vermisse ich ein
bisschen ich habe nicht das Gefühl dass
da jetzt die eine ganz große Aufstand
angezettelt wird klar Bernd Neuendorf
bemüht sich auf jeden Fall sehr muss man
auch anerkennen geht auf kritische
Distanz zu Infantino aber wenn es hart
auf hart kommt er zieht er dann eben
doch auch zurück offenbar und ich würde
mir wünschen dass ich verwende wieder
DFB mit anderen zusammenschließen und
die FIFA da mal richtig herausfordern
denn sonst wird sich nie was verändern
Johnny Infantino ist der Nachfolger von
sehr Platter nach der Platter dachten
wir es kann nicht schlimmer kommen es
wurde schlimmer dann in fantino kam also
bei der FIFA ist es ein Systemproblem
das ist meine Meinung und dagegen müsste
man aufstehen
lieber Jochen danke für diesen Ausblick
und danke auch dass du angesprochen hast
das Systemproblem FIFA über das wir
jetzt weiter sprechen den noch einen
schönen Abend und vielen Dank für deine
Zeit hier bei ZDF heute live danke euch
viele Grüße
also Jochen Breyer hat es angesprochen
dass System FIFA ist ein Problem Johnny
Infantino ist ein Problem denn wenn wir
über die FIFA sprechen da müssen wir
auch über ihn als mächtigsten Mann als
FIFA Boss sprechen und der hat vor dem
Start der Weltmeisterschaft in Katar wo
er übrigens auch selbst lebt diese
bizarren Aussagen hier getroffen haben
[Musik]
today I feel up
to day feel African
today I feel gay
ja mit diesen Worten von Gianni
Infantino dem FIFA-Präsidenten vor
dieser Weltmeisterschaft grüße ich jetzt
auch Alexander Koch bei uns im Stream
ehemaliger stellvertretender
Kommunikationschef bei der FIFA hallo
Herr Koch erstmal und Frage an Sie
wer soll diesen Mann wer soll Gianni
Infantino diese Worte eigentlich glauben
ich glaube niemand glaubt ihm das und
das ist wahrscheinlich so ein Albtraum
für die Kommunikationsabteilung der FIFA
denn die haben auch alle den Kopf
geschüttelt und haben sich gefragt was
ist denn hingefahren so eine Rede zu
halten ich kann mich immer anschließen
völlig Pizza
was haben Sie bei diesen Worten bei
diesen Ankündigungen gedacht und wenn
wir jetzt auch schon zwei Tage später
die Taten sehen das verbieten der One
Love Kapitänsbinde steht so im
Widerspruch was haben sie da gedacht
ich konnte auch erst nicht glauben was
ich da tatsächlich gehört habe und
irgendwie hat das aber noch mal mehr
bewiesen
wie er auch ganz klar was für er für
eine Position auch vertritt und der ist
ganz weit weg von hier im Hier und Jetzt
und der ist ganz woanders und ich glaube
dass er da sowieso sehr sehr falsch auch
beraten ist und ähm Dinge auch auf
eigene Faust macht und wir sehen uns ja
gegenwärtig dann man love finden werden
dann verboten also das ist total konträr
total im Widerspruch und wir sehen uns
immer wieder das ist eben auch diese
Weltmeisterschaft also da kommen immer
wieder Dinge auf wo wir immer nur mit
dem Kopf schütteln können aber ich
glaube es reicht jetzt auch mit dem Kopf
schütteln ich sehe es tatsächlich so
dass wir jetzt auch Taten sehen müssen
dass wir diese nationalen Verbände
irgendwie noch mehr in die Pflicht
nehmen müssen weil wir können davon
ausgehen dass von der FIFA so nichts
mehr kommen wird
passt auch was Herr Koch auch ganz kurz
bevor ich da bevor sie einsteigen nur
ganz kurz weil das an dieser Stelle
passt von Stefan Kleinknecht per Mail
auch er schlägt in dieselbe Kerbe er
sagt ich bin große Fußballfan aber mehr
als enttäuscht wie Frau Teckel das
gesagt hat vom DFB auch von den Spielern
wenn es nicht weh tut und gut aussieht
kann jeder für rechte einstehen aber wer
wirklich dahinter steht der vertritt
seine Überzeugung gerade dann wenn es
etwas kostet ich finde es feige und
schwach und kann das Gerede von es ist
unser Traum nicht mehr hören schade
Chance vertan dass die Meinung dass
Users jetzt die Herr Koch was wollten
sie sagen ja ich wollte dir nur
Ergänzung sagen also sie haben gesagt
falsch beraten ich weiß eben nicht ob
der wirklich beraten wird der macht
ziemlich viel allein also zumindestens
innerhalb der FIFA hat kaum jemand
Zugang zu ihm und er entscheidet das
allein und was das verbieten dieser
Regenbogen Armbinden betrifft da gibt's
einen klare Anweisung von der FIFA dass
das nicht verboten werden darf und dass
die nicht abgenommen werden dürfen aber
das hat sich Sicherheitspersonal gemacht
und das hatten wir leider auch schon in
Deutschland in Brasilien
dass diese Sicherheitsleute oftmals ein
bisschen übereifrig sind und dann Sachen
machen die aber nicht im Einklang sind
mit der FIFA und der letzte Punkt den
Sie gesagt haben die FIFA wird sich
nicht ändern ich bestimme ihn absolut zu
und einfach nur dass man es weiß die
FIFA sind eben diese 20011
Nationalverbände und niemand der hier in
Zürich sitzt und arbeitet und diese 200
und 11 Nationalverbände haben ist nicht
auf die Reihe bekommen ein
Gegenkandidaten für Infantino
aufzustellen und von daher ist hier auch
große Überraschung und ich weiß es von
vielen Leuten auch eine gewisse
Enttäuschung zu spüren absolut auf
diesen Aspekt da werden wir auch gleich
noch in der Diskussion schauen bleiben
wir vielleicht noch mal chronologisch
auch beim Montag Herr Koch wie bewerten
sie da das Vorgehen der FIFA von
Infantino die One Love Binde zu
verbieten
also das ist jetzt eine etwas
komplizierte Diskussion ich bin der
Meinung dass eine Mannschaft nicht
allein entscheiden darf auch wenn es ein
Menschenrecht ist was Sie auf Ihrer
Binde haben und von daher war ich bis
vor kurzem mich korrigiert korrigiere
meine aus Äußerung gleich auch wieder
ein bisschen war ich der Meinung dass
wenn die FIFA als Kampagne ausgibt Nein
zu Diskriminierung und hat so eine
Armbinde dann deckt das erstmal alles ab
und dann sollten sich da alle verwende
dran halten weil ich glaube das ist
nicht gut ist wenn ein Land sagt jetzt
spielen wir gegen den Iran und dann
wählen wir zum Beispiel dass
Menschenrecht der Gleichberechtigung
oder man spielt gegen die USA und
spricht sich gegen Folter aus Stichwort
guatanamo oder man spielt gegen die
Schweiz und denkt an Nestler und sagt
jeder hat das Recht auf sauberes
Grundwasser dann wird Politik auf das
Spielfeld getragen und dann werden dann
dann wird der Sport kaputt gemacht und
darum wäre ich unter solchen voraus
dagegen das muss abgestimmt sein was ich
jetzt aber ja gelernt habe ist dass
diese sieben Verbände schon im September
den Antrag eingereicht haben diese One
Love Armbinde einzusetzen und dann ist
es natürlich ein komplettes Versagen der
FIFA erstens auf diese diese Anforderung
oder diese dieses Begehren nicht
einzugehen darauf nicht zu antworten und
das nicht auszudiskutieren also ich weiß
übrigens von vielen Leuten auch
innerhalb der FIFA die sonst sich um
diese Themen kümmern die waren sich
dessen gar nicht bewusst dass ein Antrag
vorlag also auch das ist auf oberster
Ebene entschieden worden und dann ist es
in der Tat ein Schlag ins Gesicht für
diese Verbände die dann kurz vor der WM
erfahren ihr dürft übrigens nicht tragen
und dann verstehe ich den Unmut so aber
dann sind wir ja bei einem spannenden
und weiteren interessanten Aspekt der
dafür spricht dass es vielleicht ja auch
ein geplanter FIFA hinter halt so machte
Demonstration gewesen sein könnte also
acht Wochen zu Binde schweigen und dann
einen Tag vorher sagen nee macht mal
nicht worum geht es dann Herr Koch
Infantino da ist es dann nur die
Botschaft nur die Binde oder ist es auch
das Zeichen ich präsentiere jetzt hier
meine Macht gegen euch europäische
Verbände
also ich kann natürlich nicht genau
sagen was er sich dabei denkt bei seiner
Aktion ich könnte es mal vermuten aus
meiner eigenen Erfahrung dass die FIFA
vielleicht gesagt hat gut da gibt es
diesen Antrag auch was für dieses Thema
One Love zu machen dann machen wir
vielleicht eine eigene Kampagne und wir
denken das schon irgendwie mit ab und
dann fällt das da drunter aber es gibt
aus meiner Sicht keine Entschuldigung
dafür so einen Antrag nicht zu
beantworten und sofort in den Dialog zu
gehen mit den Verbänden weil das eine
tickende Zeit bauen ist also ich muss
ihn ehrlich sagen ich kann das nicht
nachvollziehen was
infantine oder das Top-Management da
geritten hat so mit diesem Thema
umzugehen sie haben es gerade
angesprochen dass Sie den Eindruck haben
das Infantino und auch andere höhere
Funktionäre in der FIFA nicht mehr
dienen Realitätsbezug haben nicht mehr
die botenhaftung haben was glauben sie
ist es ein geplantes Zeichen so nach dem
mottosität her wenn ich will dann macht
ihr das schon dann tanzt ihr nach meiner
Pfeife also Machtdemonstration wie
würden sie es einschätzen
ich weiß nur dass diese One Love Bünde
ja auch ein Kompromiss war und dass wir
auch da schon ein wenig eingeknickt sind
und gesagt haben okay dann machen wir
halt keine Regenbogenfarben dann immer
diese one love-bünde wo sich ja auch
schon sehr viele darüber aufgeregt haben
und im Hinblick darauf dass er dann
unsere Innenministerin dahin gereist ist
und mit einem sicherheitsversprechend
zurückkommt und irgendwie paar Tage
später der wm-botschafter eben
sogenannte Aussagen trifft die wir heute
Abend auch schon gehört haben das
Homosexualität in geistiger Schaden sei
also all das zeigt mir einfach noch mal
ganz klar dass die FIFA macht was sie
will dass sie ohne Rücksicht auf
Verluste und dem Geld auch folgt und am
Ende des Tages sowohl die Rechte von
queren Menschen von von anderen Menschen
einfach nicht gelten und das ist etwas
was mich ähm woran ich mich persönlich
natürlich als Menschenrechtsaktivistin
sehr störe nämlich
dass ich eben auch mir wünsche dass
Leute in die Verantwortung gehen nicht
einknicken Haltung zeigen und da geht es
wirklich das ist ja das tut ja nicht weh
mit dieser one love-binde dann auf dem
Platz zu gehen und diese gelbe Karte zu
bekommen und wenn es dann auch noch
andere Sanktionen gegeben hätte
sportliche ja aber dann wäre es
wenigstens eine Haltung gewesen dann
wäre das ein Statement gewesen und das
hat mir komplett gefehlt deswegen wir
haben doch jetzt in den letzten Wochen
in den letzten Jahren jetzt ganz
deutlich auch festgestellt und wer heute
noch was anderes behauptet weiß ich auch
nicht aber dass die FIFA kompromisslos
ist das ist grubbellos ist und macht was
sie will und ich glaube wenn wir uns
damit
beschäftigen dann sind die Verbände wir
reden hier von 211 Verbänden die
wirklich eine Macht sind da auch
irgendwie eine Wandel hat herbeizuführen
und dafür müssen wir laut sein dafür
dürfen wir nicht schweigen weil wir
schweigt stimmt auch einfach zu und das
ist ja das was
am Ende des Tages Infantino in diesem
Fall auch bestätigt dass er das alles
durchgedrückt bekommt
sie haben auch die Willkürlichkeit der
FIFA angesprochen und die zeigt sich
auch an Stellen wie das gesagt wird zum
Verbot der Binde nein wir wollen hier
keine politischen Zeichen also Argument
vorgeschoben wird dann aber auch wieder
einen Tag später ein Verfahren gegen
ecuadorianische Fans eingeleitet wird
wegen offenbar homophober Äußerung und
Gesänge der Fans von Seiten der FIFA und
ein weiteres Beispiel dass sie
Willkürlichkeit unterschreibt auch bei
der WM 2018 schon in Russland da wurden
Spieler Kroatiens verwandt nach dem
Viertelfinalsieg gegen das russische
Team für Aussagen in Richtung pro
Ukraine Herr Koch Mann hat das Gefühl
die FIFA wird immer dann politisch wenn
es ihnen in den Kram passt und ich kann
mir diese Willkürlichkeit auch nicht
erklären Sie also ich sehe da irgendwie
gesagt überhaupt keine Willkürlichkeit
ich finde das absolut korrekt jemanden
zu verwahren wenn er solche politischen
Statements auf dem Platz gibt weil dort
einfach nicht zu suchen haben weil sie
dem Sport Schaden es trägt auf einmal
den Konflikt Ukraine Russland auf diesen
Platz und der hat dort nichts zu suchen
weil da einfach das Spiel kaputt macht
und die die Verwarnung der Fans die
jetzt homophobe gesende gemacht haben
das ist eine absolute Konsequenz die
können sie seit Jahren verfolgen das ist
eine relativ strikt ein relativ strikter
Umgang mit null Toleranz was Rassismus
und Homophobie betrifft das wird
bestraft also ich sehe da jetzt keine
keine Willkür und und wenn der wenn der
katharische ist ja kein offizieller
Botschaft oder wenn dieser Mensch sagt
seine Äußerung über
Homosexualität dann ist das ja nicht die
FIFA die das sagt und das ist auch nicht
die FIFA die das gut heißt also ich sehe
mich auf einmal wieder in der Position
die FIFA zu verteidigen obwohl ich
obwohl mir eigentlich gar nicht danach
ist aber sie vermischen da sehr viele
Dinge und ehrlich gesagt überrascht sie
das dass er sowas gesagt hat
das ist ja die große Mehrheit in den
Ländern die so denkt also
was wo ich an Breyer zustimme was er
vorhin gesagt hat ist dass ich von der
FIFA erwarte dass sie zu solchen
Äußerungen Stellungen nimmt und vehement
widerspricht das erwarte ich aber das
hat mich jetzt überhaupt nicht
überrascht weil ich weiß dass die
Menschen dort so denken
aber das kann uns ja nicht nur weil wir
davon ausgehen dass Menschen so denken
kann uns das ja nicht so können wir das
ja nicht so hinnehmen das ist ja ganz
vertrauen Aussage genau
aber die FIFA hätte ja genau wie sie
sagen zu Recht sie muss dann
Klarstellung beziehen und das hat sie
auch in diesem Fall nicht getan
obwohl solche Aussagen getroffen worden
sind obwohl sich als versprechen wie
gesagt gegeben worden sind da hätte man
sich ganz klar positionieren müssen und
ich sage es noch mal die FIFA hat eine
Weltmeisterschaft einem Land gegeben
oder in die Hände eines Landes gegeben
wo Menschenrechte mit Füße getreten
werden wo Tiere Menschen verfolgt werden
und ich hätte mir seinerzeit von der
FIFA einfach nur gewünscht dass sie sich
ganz klar positionieren und sagen ich
sage nicht dass wir eine
Weltmeisterschaft nicht in der Land
geben dürfen was keine Fußballtradition
aber ich bitte euch also in dem Moment
wo kathar sich bewirbt da muss man doch
erstmal Forderungen stellen da muss man
ja erstmal sagen okay dass das und das
läuft bei euch schief kultursensibilität
ja das weiß ich am allerbesten aber
Menschenrechtsverletzung nein und das
ist ein ganz klares Zeichen und in dem
Moment wo wir diese Weltmeisterschaft
nach Kartagen geben wird geht man das
Risiko ein nicht nur dass Leute
vielleicht nicht einschalten nicht nur
das Risiko ein dass Leute vielleicht
diese Weltmeisterschaft als umstritten
sehen sondern man geht das Risiko ein
dass Menschen leben auf Spiel gesetzt
werden und das wusste man vorher dass
all das passieren das konnte man erahnen
dass das alles passiert und dennoch hat
man diese Weltmeisterschaft in dieses
Land gegeben und da bin ich dann laut
und dann sage ich auch wir haben vor 12
Jahren hätten wir schon alle sehr sehr
laut sein müssen das haben wir nicht
getan ich bin sehr froh dass wir es
jetzt alle sind und ich wünsche mir weil
ich als Menschenrecht Aktivist auch
danach noch sein sehr laut aber ich
wünsche mir dass wir weiterhin alle
gemeinsam laut sind denn uns muss unser
aller Anspruch sein dass wir in jedem
Land menschenwürdige Verhältnisse haben
ja ich da möchte ich gleich darauf
reagieren ich stimme Ihnen fast in allen
Punkten zu einfach in der in der
Darstellung noch mal die FIFA also
grundsätzlich sollte man darüber
nachdenken welche Bedingungen muss ein
Land erfüllen damit es überhaupt in den
in den näheren Kreis derjenigen
Kandidaten kommt die ausgewählt werden
dürfen und das ist sehr schwierig aber
das finde ich absolut richtig dass man
darüber nachdenkt ich sage Ihnen nur
vielleicht überrascht sie das die FIFA
die FIFA war ja nicht für die Vergabe
nach Katar die hat versucht das zu
verhindern es waren deutsche Agenturen
die Bewerbung gemacht haben ein
deutsches Büro was die stadiendesignt
hat mit dem wunderschönen Namen Albert
Speer und es sind deutsche Firmen die
dort die Stadien aufbauen und die
Infrastruktur aufbauen unter anderem die
U-Bahn und die Mitte für die
Verhältnisse der Arbeiter verantwortlich
sind das hat uns in der FIFA selber
überrascht wenn Sie diesen Aspekt sehen
Sie absolute
gebe ich Ihnen Recht und wenn sie ich
möchte an dieser Stelle sehr gerne mein
Podcast empfehlen ausverkauft der bei
Spotify zu hören ist weil ich wir eben
bei diesem Podcast genau diese
Komplexität dieser Weltmeisterschaft
eben durchleuchten und das weiß ich auch
und deswegen sage ich auch ganz klar
dass alle da in Verantwortung genommen
werden müssen und alle da natürlich auch
entsprechend bei diesem Podcast ihr
sozusagen ihr Fett weg kriegen und das
ist ganz ganz wichtig dass wir auch
nicht mit erhobenen Zeigefinger nach
Katar gucken und zeigen denn am Ende des
Tages hat kathar sich auch an einem
System bedient was da war und hat das
Spiel mitgespielt und dennoch gerade bei
den vergaben Forderungen müssen
eingehalten werden dann muss man gucken
das konnten das konsequent überwacht
wird und da sehe ich dann schon die FIFA
aber in Verantwortung solche Dinge eben
dann auch konsequent durchzudrücken und
auch zu beobachten
ganz kurz ich gehe dann noch mal ganz
kurz rein und Stelle natürlich auch noch
mal klar dass es natürlich richtig ist
gegen homophobe Fangesänge Verfahren
einzuleiten absolut was ich nur immer
noch nicht verstanden habe ist die
Willkürlichkeit der Argumentation von
politischen Zeichen an der Stelle dann
zum Beispiel bei One Love bei der One zu
sagen die Anzeichen für
Gleichberechtigung für Toleranz für die
sexuelle Gleichberechtigung auch sein
sollte dazu sagen dass verbieten wir
eben weil wir nicht politisch sein
sollen das verstehe ich einfach nicht
nein das ist es ja nicht das ist auch
die Note Diskrimination ist ja wenn man
so will auch politisch ich finde das
muss nur einfach organisiert sein und
das muss gemeinschaftlich bestimmt
worden sein was jetzt die offizielle
Kampagne ist das ist nicht und da bringe
ich jetzt den Ausdruck will hier rein
das ist nicht in Abhängigkeit ist
vielleicht von dem Team gegen dass man
die spielt oder in dem Land in dem man
gerade ist und sich dann jeweils anpasst
sondern ich sage wenn man vorher darüber
gesprochen hätte ich kann mir durchaus
vorstellen dass FIFA auf Note
discommination verzichtet hätte und
stattdessen One Love nimmt spricht
überhaupt nichts dagegen und darum bin
ich auch so enttäuscht dass obwohl
dieser Antrag seit September vorliegt
diese Diskussion anscheinend zumindest
mit den Verbänden nicht stattgefunden
hat man darüber nicht geredet hat und
gemeinsam nach einer Lösung gesucht hat
denn die Verbände sind ja die FIFA also
da haben sie schon recht die haben ja
eigentlich auch die Macht und wenn die
nicht einverstanden sind mit dem was die
Administration nachher umsetzt dann
müssen sie sich wehren
darf kann ich mir durchaus vorstellen
die spricht überhaupt nichts dagegen
dass die dann alle spielen die FIFA hat
auch sagen können in der Vorrunde no
Diskrimination im Achtelfinale
Viertelfinale One Love und im Finale
irgendwas drin ist alles mögliche
Mann ist hat sie aber am Ende nicht
gemacht so das müssen wir halt auch
festhalten
genau kein klares Zeichen gesetzt und
ähm das auch alles in Kauf genommen auch
diesen ganzen
diese ganze diese ganze Wut der Fans und
das ist das was mich am Ende des Tages
also ich ich finde die FIFA kommt auch
vor allem Entschuldigung die FIFA kommt
hier auch bei allem ähm dennoch sehr gut
weg und ich finde schon dass sie da eine
riesen Verantwortung hat gesagt und
definitiv haben die Verbände die Macht
die FIFA unter Druck zu setzen und das
ist das was ich mir wie gesagt auch
Wünsche von den nationalen Verbänden da
eben nicht still zu sein nicht ruhig zu
sein sondern da wirklich Druck auszuüben
ja da stimme ich Ihnen vollkommen zu ich
wünsche mir das auch dass die Verbände
viel mehr Druck ausüben nicht wünsche
mir im Interesse der FIFA Mitarbeiter
die zum Großteilen sehr guten Job machen
dass die Kommunikationspolitik der FIFA
sich ändert denn wenn Sie also im Grunde
genommen was Infantino da gerade macht
ist genau das Gegenteil davon wie man
Krisen Kommunikation macht er könnte
oder er oder seine
Kommunikationsabteilung könnte zu all
diesen Themenstellungen nehmen und zwar
immer sofort und erklären und begründen
und dann hätten wir schon viel weniger
Stress
ich danke Ihnen beiden für diese
Diskussion und auch für den Ausblick
took bytecal ehemalige profifußballerin
unter anderem für den HSV und den ersten
fC Köln vielen Dank für ihre
Positionierung und vielen Dank natürlich
auch an Alexander Koch ehemaliger
stellvertretender Kommunikationschef der
FIFA für ihre Einblicke und für ihre
Zeit heute auch bei ZDF heute live danke
schön
danke auch an euch fürs mit diskutieren
fürs Fragen stellen und ich möchte die
Sendung Band mit einem hoffnungsvollen
Ausblick auch eines Users von Uwe Helme
der hat uns per Mail geschrieben er hat
gesagt auch noch mal seine Meinung die
ganze Mannschaft hätte mit der Binde
auflaufen sollen das ist seine Meinung
sie sind ein Team vielleicht machen sie
es ja am Sonntag gegen Spanien ein
Punktabzug so sagt er ist nach dem Spiel
ja heute eh egal das war es von uns bis
zum nächsten mal hier bei ZDF heute live
vielen Dank fürs zuschauen macht's gut
tschüss